a team of private firefighters those
saved Kim and Kanye's 60 million dollar
mansion according to TMZ now to break
all that down
Harrah's et reporter Brendan Joffrey on
Brendan explained to us wait well yes
private firefighters yes yeah so I
actually did some research on this
private firefighting it is an actual
industry and they make up about 4.3
percent according to this website four
point three percent of the nation's
total firefighters now private
firefighters are employed by private
firefighters I myself have never heard
of it but when I did some research that
is what turned up so it is an actual
industry within firefighters that
actually work for you know government
agencies they are operated by private
companies there that's the difference
Wow that blew my mind cuz initially when
I heard it I was like can you pay a
firefighter to step away from the duty
of the community to protect your home
but that makes a lot of sense now so how
did the firefighters save the
neighborhood I know this is all
according to TMZ right so TMZ says that
the team these private firefighters were
armed with hoses and they actually dug
ditches around Kim and Kanye's Hidden
Hills home and those ditches created a
fire break so essentially kept the
flames from creeping up the property and
reaching in their house so TMZ claims
that flames were on their property but
they never actually reached the
structure of their home where word Kim
and Kanye and the family members during
all of this right so we don't have our
own independent reporting on this but if
you kind of followed the family on
social media during their evacuation
process it was very clear that Kourtney
had evacuated her home in Calabasas and
had gone to Kendall's home because she
posted from Kendall's pantry later in
the night making a joke about you know
thank you for having these cookies we
know that that night was the night the
Kendall was in New York City
filming the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show as for Kim and other members of the
family we do know they evacuated their
home as you mentioned
where they went from there is really
unclear Wow you know when I first
initially heard this I was like this is
a bit much you hire private firefighters
but if you have the privilege and the
money to do it I totally get it now I
understand but I want to know Brendan is
this a common thing do a lot of
celebrities do this from time to time
not that we know of I mean just during a
little bit of my research here before I
could jump down here with you guys it
didn't really pop up a whole lot again
there was a few reports kind of breaking
down what it is and how it all works but
I myself and I don't know about you guys
I have not heard about this or
celebrities using private firefighters
in the past we do know though that Kim
and Kanye according to TMZ got a lot of
praise from their neighbors TMZ claims
that a lot of neighbors thanked the
couple for doing this because of where
they live on the street at a cul-de-sac
apparently could have really sparked up
and not only went from their house but
from house to house this fire could have
jumped awesome well thanks Brendan for
that information no problem thanks guys
[Music]